do you ever hope they will be able to
understand
the
the early spark that created
our universe yeah you know that and the
the deep
interior of a black hole i think the the
biggest mysteries that we hope
the melding of quantum mechanics and
gravity will reveal will illuminate
and you know what question could be
more captivating than why is there
something rather than nothing right why
is there a universe at all
and will the theories that we're
developing
take us to an answer to that i don't
know
even if we truly knew what the big bang
is and that's a big question in his own
right one would still be left with the
question well okay so you've explained
the process by which
a tiny nugget of a
universe a kind of nugget of space-time
can undergo some kind of growth to yield
the world around us but
presumably in that explanation you're
going to involve mathematics
and some ingredients like quantum fields
or or matter or energy or something
where did that stuff come from you know
can we get to that level of explanation
i don't know but it is remarkable
that
if you ask what happened
a millionth of a second after the big
bang
it's not really that controversial
any longer right even though there's a
lot of argument in the field and it's
very heated right now i should say
regarding what is the right theory of
the big bang what is the right theory of
early universe cosmology where i mean
early much earlier than a millionth of a
second a lot of dissent a lot of
uh
heated arguments about that no pun
intended yeah right exactly um but but
but you go like a millionth of a second
after that yeah and and we're on pretty
firm ground isn't that amazing right you
know to understand you know what
happened from that point forward but to
go back is is is controversial so there
is this theory called inflationary
cosmology
which i would say has been the dominant
paradigm since uh early 1980s so what
does that mean roughly 40 years now it's
been the dominant cosmological paradigm
and it makes use of a curious feature of
einstein's general theory of relativity
his fear of gravity where einstein shows
us mathematically that gravity can not
only be attractive you know the kind of
gravity that we're used to things pull
together but it can also be repulsive
and that fact is then leveraged by
people like alan guth and and andre
linde and at the time paul steinhardt
and andres albrecht and others to say
okay if we had a little nugget in the
earlier universe which was
filled with the stuff that yields this
repulsive gravity well that would have
blown everything apart it would cause
everything to swell
beautiful explanation for what the bang
in the big bang was and then people
mathematically analyze the consequences
of this idea and they make predictions
for
tiny temperature differences across the
night sky that in principle could be
measured
you send up balloons you send up
satellites with very refined
thermometers and they measured the
temperature of the night sky and the
statistical distribution of the
temperature differences agrees with the
mathematical predictions yeah
i mean
it's amazing you just sort of have to
stand in awe of of this insight so you
think
aha the theory has been established but
scientists are an incredibly skeptical
bunch and some scientists including one
of the people who helped develop the
theory of the outset paul steinhardt
comes along and says well yeah it's done
this theory's done pretty well so far
but they're aspects of this theory
that are making me lose confidence for
instance this theory seems to suggest
that there might be other universes
like how do you make sense of a theory
that suggests other universes or are
there others who come along and say this
theory seems to um
talk about length scales that are
minuscule even by the so-called plank
length the sort of shortest length that
we can imagine making sense of in a
theory of quantum gravity how do you
make sense of that and so and so they
develop a list of of things that they
consider to be chinks in the
inflationary cosmological theories armor
and they develop other ideas which they
claim
yield the same predictions as inflation
and cosmology for those temperature
differences across space but don't
suffer from these problems and then the
inflationary cosmology folks say no no
no hang on you know your theory suffers
from different problems and so the
arguments goes it's a healthy debate
talk about real debates in science
so when you ask what's up with the big
bang
i don't know right now um if you would
have asked me five years ago
maybe even less than that three or four
years ago i've said look
inflation on cosmology has some issues
but the package of explanations it
provides is so potent
and the issues that beset it are
seemingly solvable to me that i would
imagine it's going to in the end win out
i would still say that today but i
wouldn't say it as loudly i wouldn't say
it as confidently i think it's worth
thinking about alternate ideas and it
could be the case that the paradigm at
some point shifts
does dark matter and dark energy fit
into the
shifting of the explanations for those
yeah certainly so so dark energy has uh
in in the inflationary theory
is kind of a big mystery so
dark energy is the
observational
realization in the last 20 years that
not only is the universe expanding it's
expanding ever more quickly
something is still pushing things
outward
and the explanation is that there's like
a residual version of the repulsive
gravity from the early universe but it's
such a strange number when you write
that amount of dark energy using the
relevant units in the theory of quantum
gravity it's a decimal point followed by
like a hundred and twenty zeros and then
a one
we're not used to those kinds of
numbers in physics we're used to
a half
one
pi
e square to two those are the kinds of
fundamental numbers that emerge in our
explanations of the world and we look at
this bizarre number decimal point all
these zeros and one we say
something's wrong there like where would
that number
have come from now there are people who
suggest resolution to it so it's not
like we're totally in the dark on it but
those people like paul steinhardt who
have alternate cosmological theories
cyclic cosmologies as they call it claim
that they have a more natural
explanation of the dark energy that it
naturally feeds into a cyclical process
that
is their cosmological paradigm so yeah
if the
cosmology should change it's conceivable
our view of dark energy may change from
deeply mysterious to deeply integrated
into a different paradigm that is
possible
you